the podcast you guys did over the
weekend mr olympia 200 000 people tuned
in worldwide to listen to and i was
amazing dude we missed you
yeah because we were thinking that you
were going to do a pose down closed down
pose down with mario
and and roy
let me tell you
roy did a good job roy did a great job
you know he was a
former npc competitor he competed at the
amateur show actually it was one of my
shows don't make this about roy please
let's make this but he did i'm not even
gonna
he's all about muscle madden over here
this dude yeah forgotten more about the
uh the human body than we'll ever shout
out to big romney for winning you know
shout out
for winning and brandon curry looked a
little bit pissed off because i think he
he thought he could have won it and uh
uh i like i like curry's attitude you
know uh
rami that's back to back for him which
is cool to see that that's huge yeah was
he the favorite yeah by far he was the
favorite he was he lived up to
expectations he's two-time mr olympian
now right yeah i mean shout out to big
rammy
you know um
i've said this before but uh after he
won last year i made sure that i told
him you have to come in better because
next year they're all kind of gunning
for you and it's always hard
that camera is blurry it's always hard
to blend it's always hard to defend
right you win one but it's hard to
defend yeah
so uh shout out to remy but uh you know
what i'm i'm happy that brandon curry
showed a little
discuss with this place i like that i
like it too yeah you know you shouldn't
just be happy oh i play second and i
love that no man you should be pissed
nobody was more pissed than hottie man
yeah
you know that's a
look
i think during that webcast like we all
thought that hottie had a major chance i
believe even sean ray and richard sperry
while they were doing theirs had hottie
as the most conditioned guy in the show
and he was pretty complete it might have
been a size issue you know because he
was definitely giving up
i mean jeez did you know that he uh that
randy can you put up the picture sky
just to see the top three mr olympia did
you know that ramy weighed in at the uh
at the press conference at 303. wow
he was in a suit mind you but
i mean you're pushing
300 pounds 300 pounds is that the
biggest ever to win it or no was ronnie
still big enough to win it ronnie was
295.
and what were you when you won it oh
gosh heavy 16 no i probably looked 260
but i was 248. wow
okay so i mean you know hottie is
definitely on he's on the third he's on
the far right yeah for anyone that
doesn't know but honey gave like
a really good argument as to being at
least second in this you know because
you look at the quads you know compared
to everybody else it's just more deep
separation but
you know i think when you do the quarter
turns and you do all the other poses i
can understand why the judges picked
grammy you know i mean look at his he
looks he like dwarfs these these massive
men look at the size of this guy who the
one in the middle one in the middle yeah
that's big romney for you yeah that's
big romney did he officially change his
name to big romney that's his name they
called him that so i met romney like 11
years ago in kuwait
and he was
just getting ready to turn pro i believe
he's egyptian
yes okay or i think he just turned pro i
remember seeing him uh compete i thought
i remember talking to dennis james i go
this guy
just turned pro he's like yes i go
okay you got to get back in the gym this
is a guy that definitely if he gets it
together i mean he's going to be mr
olympia someday and he did it twice so
congrats to big ramy again
i know one phrase in egyptian because
there was an egyptian girl in high
school that i was super into it so i
learned that
now it's which i guess was uh a
bastardization of like i love you i have
no idea did it work no no it actually it
actually means a complete
difference so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you